scalloped walls have been brewing in
these waters for many years but in
recent days they've reached a climax
intimidation and violence is said to
have been used to get the Brits away
from French waters the private meetings
being held in London tomorrow to try and
rein in tensions but the likes of carl's
say a lot of damage has already been
done throw the lights of stuff like this
big heavy steel metal shackles that's
enough to smash a window or injure
someone basically it was just last week
that this footage emerged showing boats
colliding in the channel it's alleged
that the French also threw smoke bombs
and rocks who was there that night and
says it was pretty terrifying just with
a masterful shot the 40 French boat
surround us sort of shooting flares
sunshine abuse surrounding the boats
stuff especially British government's
going to have to stand up but Hayden
behind politics and brexit and all this
sweet answers about common sense after
revealing French boats are stopped from
fishing off the coast of Normandy at
this time of year because their
government wants to preserve shellfish
numbers but British boats face no such
restriction you might think that's
unfair but it does happen the other way
around as well in fact in recent days
French fishermen caught this massive
haul of 44 rare bluefin tuna off the
coast of Jersey in the Channel Islands a
place where British fishermen aren't
allowed and that too has increased
tensions even further rules and
regulations of bitumen are undoubtedly
very very complicate
when it comes to Scala the ones down off
the Normandy coast are among the richest
in the world and so you can see why so
many people want to fish there
but the French say if they are
overfished all year round and there
won't be enough left for future
generations
indeed French fishermen want action as
does the Agriculture Minister yesterday
been speaking on television for says ooh
regret - the French Navy is ready to
intervene in case of clashes and then
undertake checks
because I'll remind you that the
situation is regrettable the French
hoped that brexit will stop English and
Scottish fishermen entering their waters
but some believe it could also make
things worse if common rules for fishery
management are removed
who knows whether tomorrow's meeting
will calm things down or stoked tensions
further either way British fishermen say
they'll be heading back out to the bay
de sin come Thursday Rebecca Williams
Sky News in Brixham